CBS News contributor Bob Schieffer has
covered nine count them nine presidents
he joins us at the table now Bob good
morning good morning what the hell is
going on yeah good question you know my
Air Force training comes into play here
because the Air Force song is off we go
into the wild blue yonder and every time
I wake up the now I'm just thinking here
we go again
I mean a I'm not going to say I've never
seen anything like this because every
time I say it the young people around
here it's become a drinking game you
know that every time I say I've never
seen anything like it
here we go so interesting I'm not going
to lose that tournament well it is
Friday and you've covered presidents
White House when people use salty
language but on the record and against a
chief of staff and against the
president's chief strategist using words
and talking about self fellatio it's
it's not like nothing I've ever seen
yeah but you're smiling at the way she
expressed it aren't you being very
diplomatic but it's sex act on himself
so talking about Stevie I know how is
that even physically possible number one
and number two when you hear something
like that Bob are you offended
are you offended are you disappointed
are you saddened by it because totally
serious stuff when I when you listen to
it and the children are listening and
parents are listening and I think we're
the United States of America using that
kind of language on the record from a
high-ranking White House official it's
embarrassing yeah it is embarrassing
yeah it is embarrassing for the nation
and and the idea that someone who
represents the President of the United
States I mean look my standards are not
too high but I got some yeah you know
and and that kind of talked you don't
hear that behind the shoots at the Fort
Worth rodeo you know and then Devine the
shoots at the port well I I've been a
lot of places Charlie and I it's just
but I tell you I think that we're gonna
look back on this week this might be
some kind of a turning point
also because there's an inflation point
I tell you the way that Jeff sessions
has been treated it did not go over well
with Republicans in the United States
Senate they don't like it he gave up a
Senate seat to go serve the president
that's an honorable thing to do and hang
him out to dry like they've done
I think that's had more of an impression
on that made more of an impression about
this than any other thing he's done and
that does not help him he needs us and
how about last night I mean here you
have in the dead of the night this
Senate vote on health care you've got
Mike Pence the vice president standing
over John McCain's desk Trump calls John
McCain to try and lobby him and then and
then John McCain votes no bombs down
yeah I tell you and they've got
themselves in a fix now and they you
know my wife Pat who is kind of the
brains and our family she came up with a
great plan on health care she said you
know what I think they should do the
women of the Senate how many of them are
there 13 mm-hmm there's a large group
and there they're a very classy group of
people and he said they are then the
other party are the two that are making
a difference they ought to get together
and write a health care plan and and see
what the rest of the Senate thinks about
it and my sense is that they tried
everything else why not I thought it
might be a pretty good at all going Bob
the point I think when we if the
president does not get his business in
order here I think it's going nowhere
I think his agenda is going to go right
out the window I mean you can't have you
know he's he's got to get together with
people in Washington and and find some
way to work together but why do you make
it so long this is going on the Russian
probe continues under Bob Miller and at
the same time he's got no legislation at
all on the horizon and you heard what
Lindsey Graham said yesterday he said
unless he said if he tries to fire Jeff
Sessions he said this may be the
beginning of the end of the Trump
administration should be held to pay but
Bob this is what fascinates me there are
so many Republicans who disagree with
how the president's behaving what he's
saying what he's
but they are not speaking up what do you
make about that that they're not saying
mr. president please stop mr. scare
Moochie please stop they're saying it
privately yeah and I understand but
that's where it starts okay and and I
think there's something going on there I
think I think Donald Trump is in worse
shape today than he was at the beginning
of this week just from a standpoint of
getting his legislation passed working
on his agenda yeah
always good to have you at the table and
our best tip at the brains of your
operation that's a keeper household
thank you something we all knew yes no
bad